hello and welcome to another week of
nothing new on breath of the wild too
wow even saying there's no new news on
the sequel feels old at this point
but while we've been wandering around
this no news desert like a bunch of
hype-starved
nomads there have been quite a few
videos made by quite a few different
creators across youtube space that have
served to voice the opinions of said
creators regarding what we would like to
see in the sequel to breath of the wild
you know in the case that it should ever
release i haven't really taken part in
these kinds of wishlist style videos
except for when i was
a part of this video from the legendary
hyrule gamer but that was quite a while
ago
so i figured what the heck it's been
long enough let's talk about my thoughts
regarding the sequel since i don't think
i've ever given you guys my complete
opinions on the matter
but we're gonna switch it up a bit we're
not necessarily gonna talk about what i
want to see happen but rather what i
don't want to see happen
so welcome to my list of the seven
possible ways that the sequel to breath
of the wild could be ruined
let's get right to it first up i would
be disappointed to see them use the
exact same map with no geographical
changes for breath of the wild 2.
even though it is pretty likely that
they will in fact be introducing new
areas and such
i mean just look at the caverns from the
trailer the reason why i mentioned this
is because mr aonuma did directly state
that they wanted to return to the same
hyrule from breath of the wild
meaning there are probably plans in
place to either use
all or large portions of the current map
of hyrule
if for some reason nintendo does not
include any new areas then we'd be stuck
exploring the same map we've already
been exploring for the past
four years now and unlikely as it is i
think everyone would be decently
disappointed in that
this does beg the question though where
would the new ares be located
my personal opinion on the matter is a
further expanded underground area
actually
and you can gather a bit more info on
that opinion of mine with a previous
theory video i did which i will link to
in the description if you're interested
i do hope though that no matter what new
areas are introduced they won't take
away from the free roam aspect that
breath of the wild is famous for
secondly i'd be disappointed if they
limited water movement
again like they did in breath of the
wild you see ever since the olden days
of a link to the past
underwater traversal has been a staple
of the legend of zelda series
and in majora's mask completely
three-dimensional underwater swimming
was introduced and has appeared in the
game's following twilight princess and
skyward sword
with the exception of the wind waker but
wind waker made up for it by including
you know an entire ocean so i ain't mad
in breath of the wild i legitimately did
not enjoy swimming and would actually
avoid getting into the water at all
costs if i didn't absolutely have to
and this was for some pretty good
reasons too not only can you not do
anything under the surface of the water
but you also move
cripplingly slowly and expend a hefty
amount of stamina whenever you try to
swim
not slowly ultimately the best thing you
can do in the game to enhance water
movement even a little bit is equip some
armor that makes you swim a bit faster
but also makes you spend stamina faster
as a result making it not really a buff
at all in the sequel if they keep water
travel the same way i'll be decently
disappointed
even if they still don't want to include
underwater traversal for whatever reason
at least allow the players some way to
enhance water movement like i don't know
water walking boots or the ability to
make ice platforms
i mean quicker forming flat ice
platforms or actual true water speed
buff that isn't also cancer to your
stamina wheel something to make
water great again thirdly and this is a
pretty common one but i figured i'd
mention it here with my own thoughts as
well
i'll be disappointed if they keep weapon
durability the same
not only do weapons break in like 20
hits in breath of the wild but once they
gone
they gone there's no saving or restoring
a weapon's life once it has
died in battle breath of the wild was
the first zelda game to format its
gameplay after open world adventure
games like skyrim so it does make sense
that changeable weapons and durabilities
and such would be copied from these
kinds of games but do you know what
those games also
include in addition to durability repair
what a concept i mean come on why does
the weapon have to shatter worse than my
heart on valentine's day 2015 whenever
its durability runs out
why not just sit unusable in your bags
or decrease its damage until you can get
it repaired at a blacksmith or something
this is one of the most common tropes in
open world video games and it's one that
i think
should 100 be implemented in breath of
the wild if the breakable weapons return
which by the way is up in the air
currently since link is shown to already
have the master sword in the trailer i
guess we'll just have to see what
happens
number four is about quest rewards i'm
assuming there will be quests and side
quests in the sequel as there have been
with
literally every other zelda game so far
and in so doing i'd be very disappointed
if there are still no
real unique quest rewards think about it
in all of breath of the wild
across all of its many side quests dlc
quests not included there's only one
quest that i can remember
that actually gives you a unique quest
reward and that is the quest to help out
with the citizens of gerudo town and
obtain the thunderhelm actually now that
i think about it there is one other
quest that lets you get the fish pants
from zora's domain but it's literally
just those two quests okay
every other quest is like oh man thanks
for helping here's
soup or here's an apple or here's
exactly three mushrooms
it's like yeah that's cool thanks for
the mushroom but i could have just
picked some of those up in the woods
over there but yeah cool thanks
there needs to be more actual meaningful
unique quest rewards in the sequel like
actual relics or gadgets that change or
augment the way you play the game
or unique weapons or armor pieces one of
the best examples of how this should
work would be like the masks in majora's
mask
just more in the fifth place again this
is a more common belief to share but
i'll be
extremely disappointed if dungeons do
not return
in the sequel and i don't mean more
little mini dungeons
i mean actual in-depth stylized ominous
beautiful
expansive innovative intricate
puzzle-filled classic zelda dungeons
sorry i get a little passionate about
this one because even though technically
speaking breath of the wild did have a
large portion of dungeon content more
than the previous games
it was all split up and scattered
throughout the map in forms of little
minis called shrines and a couple
slightly less minis called divine beasts
that were each pretty creative but still
way too short i'd rather see the return
of a few
large dungeons than a few hundred minis
even if it means doing away with the
mini dungeons entirely if that makes
sense
6. i will be disappointed if ganondorf
is once again
a mindless monster in the sequel one of
the biggest things i always felt was
missing from breath of the wild and
preventing it from feeling like a truly
true zelda game in its hearty heart was
its lack of a villainy villain
and no putting monster ganon doesn't
really qualify as a villain
he's more of a force of nature if you
will a mindless enemy that's just
bent on destruction destruction of what
you ask
oh you know just everything really in
general i think he's upset about life to
be honest which i mean ditto but you
don't see me blowing up castles
he doesn't speak and he doesn't think he
just grosses you out and screams when he
dies
we have a huge opportunity with
ganondorf that was presented to us in
the trailer
and that is that he could once again be
an actual intelligent villain and give
that spark of life to the sequel that i
and many others always felt was missing
from breath of the wild he could also
hydrate
point number six point five six and a
half if ganondorf doesn't hydrate we
will all be disappointed
finally in seventh place i will be
sorely disappointed
if link speaks now this is a more
divisive topic since there are more
people asking for link to audibly speak
these days than there ever have been
before but hear me out
it's not like link doesn't already speak
canonically in the games
he's never actually been mute as some
people would call him but rather is just
one of those slower to speaking quicker
to listen types of people i mean how
else do people think the dialogue
options have worked in the games clearly
link does actually talk we just simply
don't hear it
and listen guys we're about to go big
brain mode here this is the reason why
nintendo normally shies away from having
their protagonists speak
speaking and speech patterns are one of
the biggest ways to judge an
individual's character it's just true i
mean most of you listening to me right
now have an image of my character in
your mind that you've only been able to
develop by listening to me talk
you probably think i'm some devilishly
handsome buff guy when in reality
actually that's pretty accurate anyway
if you omit someone's speech from being
heard their character can still be
judged but based off of what they do
instead of what they say it's a genius
concept actually in link's case
his true character resounds with every
player individually based off of what
that player has link
do in that way it's virtually impossible
for anyone to dislike link since his
character will inevitably reflect
well you now that doesn't mean he's a
hollow character by any means i mean
this isn't disney
after all there are still canonical
things link does that make parts of his
character undeniable
for instance he's a hero which implies
several details regarding his character
like bravery and chivalry and nobility
that's not something that's debatable
unless you don't complete the game but
then it's not canon anyway but anyway i
said all of that to say
that if he does actually begin to
audibly talk in full sentences in the
sequel
everything that has been built up into
link's character over the past 35 years
that the franchise has been alive that's
unique to every single zelda fan will
immediately be put in jeopardy simply
because he would now have a voice
i mean imagine if the voice actor for
link ends up giving a poor performance
now all of a sudden we'd have his
canonical voice be annoying for the rest
of time
again this isn't disney and that's my
list of the seven ways to potentially
ruin breath of the wild too
what did you guys think was i just
incoherently rambling the whole time and
being too much of a brat or am i on to
something with these points
let me know what you think in the
comments below also huge thanks for
watching and still watching if you're
hearing me say this right now
please consider dropping a like below to
get the video spread around on youtube
space and subscribe if you haven't
already for much more nintendo content
just like this
also also humongous thanks to my
supporters please give a warm and hearty
welcome to
likkan confused hylian and clint 29 who
have all generously decided to support
the channel and join the ranks of my
elite bandit crew
if you watching are interested in doing
the same and helping the next video come
to life
feel free to check out that join button
located below or follow the links to my
patreon page in the description below
also down there are links to my social
media pages so stop on by my twitter
page to stay up to date
that's all i've got for this one so as
always i hope you have a wonderful rest
of your day
this is mass intended bandit keeping it
real and signing out
peace
[Music]
you